nos piden sumar y simplificar la raíz
principal de 2x cuadrada más 4 por la
raíz principal de 8 + 3 por la raíz
principal de 2x cuadrada más la raíz
principal de 8 hagamos estas pequeñas
sumas de hecho podemos simplificar y
luego sumar o también podemos sumar y
luego simplificar se ve que podemos
sumar primero así es que hagamos eso
aquí tenemos la raíz principal de 2x
cuadradas y aquí tenemos tres veces la
raíz principal de 2x cuadrada estamos
sumando un algo con tres veces ese algo
pongamos aquí el 1 para que nos quede
claro entonces al sumar un algo más tres
veces ese algo nos da cuatro veces ese
algo el resultado de esta suma es
entonces cuatro veces la raíz cuadrada
la raíz principal de 2x cuadrada si esto
te confunde un poco piensa que este
término raíz principal de 2x cuadrada es
una nueva variable
llamémosle a esta variable a aquí
aparece también esa variable a estamos
sumando una
tres veces a lo cual nos da cuatro veces
y es la raíz principal de 2x cuadrada ya
hemos sumado eso y ahora vamos a sumar
cuatro veces la raíz principal de 8 más
una vez la raíz principal de 8 y aquí la
misma idea tenemos cuatro de estas cosas
que estoy encerrando en magenta más una
de estas cosas este uno es implícito así
es que cuatro veces algo más una vez
algo nos va a dar cinco veces algo así
que aquí tenemos más cinco veces la raíz
cuadrada de 8 más 5 veces la raíz
cuadrada de 8 4 raíz de 2 x cuadrada más
5 raíz de 8
aquí tenemos cuatro veces algo más 5
veces de otro algo estos términos los
podemos sumar sin embargo este término
de aquí sí lo puedo simplificar sabemos
que la raíz principal de 2x cuadrada es
dejar de escribir aquí primero el 4
entonces tenemos 4 x y la raíz de 2 x
cuadradas la podemos escribir como la
raíz de 2 por la raíz de x cuadrada esto
es este término de aquí y el siguiente
término sería más
la raíz cuadrada de 8 y 8 lo puedo
escribir con el producto de algo que es
un cuadro perfecto y otro algo que no es
un cuadro perfecto 8 es igual a 4 por 2
así que la raíz principal de 8 la
podemos escribir como la raíz principal
de 4 por 2 y ésta a su vez la podemos
escribir como la raíz principal de 4 por
la raíz principal de 2 y aquí que
podemos simplificar bueno sabemos que la
raíz principal de x cuadrada es el valor
de x positivo estarías tentado a poner
simplemente equis pero no no es
simplemente x es el valor de x positivo
lo cual lo escribimos como el valor
absoluto de x y porque esto es así bueno
qué tal si x es negativa supongamos que
x es menos tres cuando elevas menos tres
al cuadrado obtienes nueve pero al tomar
la raíz principal de 9 obtendríamos 3
positivos no sería el valor original de
x el cual estrés negativo sería el valor
de 3 positivo por lo cual hay que tomar
el valor absoluto y la otra cosa que es
un cuadro perfecto aquí es 4 sus raíces
principales 2 su raíz
a principales dos para ser más precisos
y ahora que tenemos bueno si invierto el
orden de los términos aquí aquí tenemos
cuatro por el valor absoluto de x por la
raíz cuadrada de 2 deja de poner lo
mejor en este mismo amarillo por la raíz
cuadrada de 2 y esto le sumamos más 55
por 25 por 12 10 este término aquí es 2
lo hemos reducido a 2 esto es 10 por la
raíz cuadrada de 2 ahora podríamos decir
que aquí ya hemos terminado o podríamos
avanzar un poquito más depende de cómo
lo quieras ver aquí tenemos cuatro veces
el valor absoluto de x de raíz de 2 y
por acá tenemos 10 veces la raíz de 2
aquí tenemos 4 veces el valor absoluto
de x por algo más 10 veces ese algo
podemos sumar los u otra manera ver esto
es que puedes factorizar la raíz
cuadrada de 2 de cualquier manera
obtenemos 4 por el valor absoluto de x
10 que multiplica que multiplica a la
raíz cuadrada principal de 2 así que
depende donde quieras llegar a este oa
este resultado de aquí más simplificado
cualquier los dos resultados funcionan
bien